traffic has been at a standstill for an
hour on this road outside the Philippine
capital Manila the policeman in charge
of directing traffic here is on a break
mark Ruiz is used to the disruption yeah
well it's uh it comes with the job
it comes with it you know especially if
you go outside you know in very urban
areas it's traffic and gridlock in areas
like this these are the portions that
can you know make things very very
tricky I see as you travel the good news
though is that the further you go out
there are less cars but that also means
less roads finally the policeman returns
and waves the drivers on mark Ruiz makes
his appointment on time 75 year old
Romania scans allas owns a so called
sorry-sorry sharp she's been running a
small convenience store in front of her
home for more than 40 years she earns
about 2 euros a day from the sale of
everyday items small sized saucers
aren't used to maintain records but this
is one of the things that we we consider
very important
romanians has learned how to keep
records from her advisor mark ruiz these
are the purchase exactly from the
suppliers so to trace of it log which
means x2 290 peso so these are actually
the logs of the ones that are inputted
her purchases from her suppliers and
before it would be more disjointed but
now after thee everything has to be
deleted delisted down keeping track of
the accounts counts the shop owner saved
money and maintained an overview of her
purchases there are more than a million
sorry-sorry shops in the philippines
they account for a third of the
country's retail trade
most of them operate independently
without outside banking the happy
knowing program wants to change that it
provides assistance to small shops many
of which are run by women one of them is
Nina Santiago
as a result of the advice and training
she received she's been able to expand
her product range now she knows for sure
what her customers want I learned a lot
from the happy noid training the most
important aspect was my personal
development I've become more confident
and have come to understand the
importance of the customer that's how I
differentiate myself from other stores
I've organized my shots to make it look
better and more inviting cosmetics for
example come in little bags many
customers can't afford to buy larger
quantities mark is pleased with the
store's progress and a very very
organized story after the if you look at
other shops they're very very messy and
so the layout of this shop actually is
very very professional and that's really
part of the training that is very
important like what was mentioned reduce
visual merchandising and that's one of
the things we actually also teach
because that allows not only the shop
owner to make sense of all of these
products because there are
literally hundreds of different kinds of
products right now in this very small
store later mark attends an information
event at a natural cosmetics store here
he meets other Filipino social
entrepreneurs it's still a relatively
small group but their number is growing
and their ideas are catching on making a
profit is not the primary goal
participating stores pay higher wages
than other businesses and offer social
benefits as well
mark founded happy noi with his college
friend BOM Aquino they've been working
together for several years Aquino was a
point of a senator in 2013 he wants to
improve conditions for social
entrepreneurs I think the first germ of
the idea probably will come from a
social entrepreneur or an idea from the
fringe and government steps in when this
is ready to be mainstream but that role
of coming up with an innovation and
coming up with that new idea I think is
still best for the social enterprises
mark travels thousands of kilometers
each year he used to work for the
multinational company Unilever but he
wanted to do something he considered
more meaningful he earns far less
working for happy noi instead he gets to
experience the feeling of helping people
on a daily basis seen explicable I mean
I wake up every day excited to go to
work and I mean that's it's like I just
you know I'm just energized and
passionate and I think this is the kind
of personal energize me I guess for the
decades to come his dream of finding
meaningful work has finally come true
happy noi roughly translates as the
happy Filipino and that's exactly how
mark ruiz feels when he's traveling
around the philippines stopping by at
one sorry-sorry shop after another